So this is phase one.
The steps we have here
are the following.
First of all, we're going to
decompose the system into components.
Secondly, we're going to
allocate responsibilities.
Those include event handling,
the delivery of the percepts and
the guaranteeing of the properties
that the system is required to have.
And third, we're going to specify
the component properties as OCL and
variants, and preimposed conditions.
>> So at this point in time can we
assume components to be objects,
when we're using OCL the syntax looks
like we're referring to objects.
>> So that's a good question.
And it doesn't have an easy answer.
Let me break it into pieces.
So we're using to specify
architecture we're using UML and
OCL which are object oriented notations.
Okay so that's one answer.
The other answer is that
object oriented programming languages
have other features like inheritance.
Okay and delegation of messages and so
on, which we're not going to
be involved with here.
We'll get to those later
when we talk about
actually designing the objects, okay?
But for now, we're thinking at
the architectural level and
we're going to think of these components
insofar as UML and OCL are concerned.
>> Okay.